the abduction and murder of a las vegas
grandmother still haunts the victim's
family in part because the accused
killer has yet to face trial 28 years
after the crime was committed why do
murder cases take years to prosecute and
is the cobid pandemic partially
responsible for a legal log jam chief
i-team reporter george knapp here now
with the story george good evening when
covid hit criminal prosecutions nearly
shut down here so did civil cases the
covet hangover is still causing ripples
throughout the system but it doesn't
fully explain the grueling slog that
characterizes the case of aydia priolo's
murder
we have a innocent older woman just
minding her own business getting her
groceries and
has evil come her way metro's cold case
detectives have filed drawers packed
with horrible homicides but the murder
of 81 year old ada priolo always stood
out
when we first profiled the cold case
killing back in february 2019 the police
didn't have a specific suspect in their
crosshairs four months later though they
identified 42 year old christopher mack
as the alleged culprit in august 1994
priolo was abducted from the parking lot
of a grocery store near her home for
four long days her daughter marilyn and
family waited in anguish for news ada's
car was found abandoned in a church
parking lot she'd been stuffed into the
trunk with her groceries then left to
die in the triple digit summer heat the
chances her being discovered in the very
short time frame it would take for her
to
succumb to the heat is you know
very short you could die an 81 year old
lady could die in an hour in the trunk
of a car
if that yes there's not one reason why
she she was killed there's not one
reason aydah's 17 year old granddaughter
tammy stillwell became a spokesperson
for the devastated family 28 years later
she's still waiting for some measure of
justice this is the fifth time the jury
trial has been canceled we've we get to
the calendar call where we get right up
to
and and it's cancelled in the three
years since the d.a agreed to prosecute
suspect christopher mack for the murder
the cases bounced between three
different judges waited for different
prosecutors to be brought up to speed
was delayed while new dna analysis was
done and for the production of new and
expanded fingerprint graphics and by
requests for continuances filed by both
sides nothing but frustration
frustration over and over and over again
you know it just keeps getting pushed
off and pushed off and pushed off las
vegas musician rob ruckus as priolo's
grandson the delays have been hard on
the entire family he says especially his
mom aydah's daughter marilyn already
suffered one stress-induced heart attack
and may not survive another one he says
the frustration the heartache that it's
putting her through is it's it's brutal
it's it's like she's getting sentenced
every time one of these appeals happens
the suspect christopher mack was 17 at
the time of the murder which meant his
fingerprints which were found on five
locations on ada's car were not in the
system until years later after he'd
committed other crimes in what is now a
long criminal career mack was already
serving time when homicide detectives
named him for priolo's murder his lawyer
argues he's already served enough time
and should be released next year one of
the delays sought by the defense came
when mack didn't want to leave state
prison for a court hearing because his
belongings might be pilfered by other
inmates another resulted from a now
notorious inmate riot at the facility
also the pandemic caused the courthouse
to essentially shut down so all criminal
cases were delayed says district
attorney steve wolfson but that coveted
long jam is now resolved he says and
wolfson is confident the priolo trial
will move forward next month we're
frustrated
because it takes so long but again
murder cases are going to take longer
because there's so much at stake and and
rightfully so but at the end of the day
we get justice
my goodness you really feel for that
family what happens next in the case
well there's a sentence a conference
where they're going to try to work out a
deal that was be acceptable to the
family i think the uh the defendants is
suggesting that he's already served
enough time just not for this crime
right uh so if that sentence said they
don't reach an agreement then it's
supposed to go to trial however you know
the family says they've been told that
the prosecutor will not be ready for
trial in september so to be another
delay we'll see
heartbreaking for that family thank you
george